while we only saw a happy couple Chris
and I know we're dealing with tension
and cheating rumors now one confidant
separates fact from fiction so what did
you guys like realize that okay this is
working out this is my moment is it I
love that idea no signs of trouble and
any rumors of infidelity are just not
true
that's according to a source close to
the couple who also tells et quote on
and Chris were so in love it's just
insane
it sure looked that way in April on the
9th in Tokyo Chris there nearly 5
year-old son Jack and Anna explored the
cherry blossoms during his Guardians
press tour beautiful honey thank you on
the 19th et was with them for the huge
Hollywood premiere
I am in awe on the way here I was so
much more nervous than Chris was days
later at his walk with Fame dedication
Anna gave this heartfelt speech thank
you for being my husband and I love you
so much I suggest every husband find a
way to have your wife give you a speech
about about what you mean to her then in
May the two began a very busy time apart
Chris was in the UK and then in Hawaii
finishing production on the Jurassic
world sequel then in June Anna was in
Vancouver filming the overboard remake
with Eva Longoria she minced Chris's
birthday once reunited in July whose of
troubles started to appear on the 30th
on a like to Twitter post about divorce
a few days earlier on the 23rd she hit
the emoji movie red carpet without her
husband and her body language was
telling you and Chris are both rats have
you been celebrating I mean some quality
time
it's been awesome yeah yeah yeah